hi everyone this is professor m dust
science and today i want to introduce
the hydrogen atom in another one of our
videos on rigorous quantum mechanics
hydrogen is the simplest of all elements
with a single proton and a single
electron however its importance cannot
be overstated hydrogen is by far the
most abundant element in the universe
making up up to 74 of all baryonic
matter for example the sun is mostly
made of hydrogen in the context of
quantum mechanics the hydrogen atom also
plays a really prominent role because it
is one of a very select group of quantum
systems that we can actually solve
analytically as such the hydrogen atom
is used as the starting point to
understand more complex quantum systems
for example other atoms we have a whole
series of videos dedicated to the study
of the quantum mechanics of the hydrogen
atom so i really encourage you to check
them out in this video we're going to
introduce the hydrogen atom and we're
also going to set up its hamiltonian so
let's go
the hydrogen atom is the simplest of all
atoms it is made of a single proton and
a single electron
so let's start with a proton
in si units it has a mass mp
of
1.67 times 10 to the minus 27 kilograms
the proton has electric charge qp
and its value is the elementary charge
that we typically denote with the letter
e
in this i units it is equal to 1.6 times
10 to the minus 19 coulomb
let's now consider the electron in si
units it has mass me of 9.11 times 10 to
the minus 31 kilograms
the electron has an electric charge
equal to qe which is equal to the
negative elementary charge in si units
it is equal to minus 1.6 times 10 to the
minus 19 coulomb
right so what do these numbers mean
let's start with the masses the ratio of
the masses mp over me is given by these
numbers
and we get 1830
in other words the proton is almost 2
000 times heavier than the electron
let's explore in more detail this large
mass difference between the proton and
the electron
for the hydrogen atom it's actually not
such a big deal because we can actually
solve the eigenvalue equation of the
hamiltonian analytically
however the mass difference between
proton and electron still proves
convenient because it helps us gain some
conceptual understanding of the
mathematical solution
in particular we're going to see later
in this video that the large mass
difference between proton and electron
means that we can almost think of the
hydrogen atom as an electron moving in
the electrostatic field generated by a
stationary proton
but this is only really the beginning of
the story
remember that hydrogen is the lightest
of all elements which means that for any
other element a starting with helium
lithium and so on
then the ratio of the mass of the
nucleus to the mass of an electron will
be even larger
crucially unlike hydrogen we cannot
analytically solve the eigenvalue
equation of the hamiltonian of other
elements
the same is true for multi-atom systems
such as chemical compounds or materials
there are no known analytical solutions
to the corresponding hamiltonian
eigenvalue equations
in all of these cases all we can do is
to find approximate solutions often
requiring the use of modern
supercomputers
and this is where the mass difference
between atomic nuclei and electrons
becomes hugely important because it
allows us to separate the motion of the
heavy atomic nuclei from that of the
light electrons using the so-called born
oppenheimer approximation
this step hugely simplifies the
equations of quantum mechanics in
multi-atom systems and forms the basis
of most numerical solutions to the
corresponding hamiltonian eigenvalue
equations
in a way we could say that much of our
quantum mechanical understanding of
chemistry material science and condensed
matter physics relies on the large
difference in the masses of atomic
nuclei and electrons
but for now let's go back to hydrogen
let's now turn to the charges we see
that the proton and the electron have
opposite charges of equal magnitude
let's first assume that the proton and
electron are classical point particles
and let's also draw a coordinate system
which i am keeping two-dimensional for
clarity but it is trivial to generalize
this to three dimensions
let the proton be at this position rp
and let the electron be at this other
position r e
two charged classical point particles
interact via an electrostatic potential
v that depends on the position of both
particles and is given by the coulomb
constant multiplying the ratio of the
product of the two charges over the
distance between them
remember that epsilon 0 is the vacuum
permittivity
now using the values of the charges in
terms of the elementary charge we get
this new expression
this minus sign here indicates that the
electrostatic potential between the
proton and electron is attractive
in other words the electrostatic
potential is what binds a proton and an
electron to form a hydrogen atom
if we now consider the proton and
electron to be quantum particles then
all we have to do is to apply the usual
quantization rule and promote the
classical electrostatic potential to be
an operator
this means that v depends on the
position operators for the proton and
the electron and is equal to the same
expression as above but now the position
coordinates become operators
we're now ready to write down the
hamiltonian of the hydrogen atom
the hamiltonian h is given by the
kinetic energy of the proton which takes
its usual form
plus the kinetic energy of the electron
which also takes its usual form
plus the potential energy described by
the electrostatic interaction that we've
just discussed
this hamiltonian is one of the most
important hamiltonians in the whole of
chemistry and the whole of physics
it allows us to learn a great deal about
the hydrogen atom and i really encourage
you to watch our series of videos on
this topic because it's fascinating
but in fact this is not the whole story
in our study of quantum mechanics we
have so far been neglecting relativistic
terms arising from einstein's special
theory of relativity
as such this hamiltonian is a
non-relativistic hamiltonian
relativistic terms become important when
we have particles moving at speeds that
are approaching the speed of light
the electrons in hydrogen do not move at
speeds that are close to the speed of
light and therefore hydrogen is a weakly
relativistic system
however modern spectroscopic techniques
do allow us to measure the small
relativistic corrections to the
predictions that arise from the
non-relativistic hamiltonian above these
relativistic terms lead to the so-called
fine structure and hyperfine structure
of hydrogen
while these are really interesting
topics our focus today will initially be
on the non-relativistic hydrogen atom
that is described directly by this
hamiltonian up here
after all the electrostatic potential
that we have is still by far the
dominant interaction in hydrogen so it
is a worthwhile starting point
in the rest of the video we will rewrite
this hamiltonian in a more convenient
form that will simplify our mathematical
analysis of the hydrogen atom in
subsequent videos
to do so we're going to use the results
that were presented in the video on two
interacting quantum particles of which
the hydrogen atom is an example
so again i encourage you to check that
video out if you haven't watched it yet
and the link is in the description as
usual
as written the hamiltonian depends on
four quantities the position and the
momentum of the proton and the position
and momentum of the electron
it will prove convenient to make a
change of variables to a new set of four
quantities the center of mass position
and total momentum described by capital
r and capital p
and the relative position and momentum
described by lowercase r and p
for the center of mass coordinates the
center of mass position
is given by this expression in terms of
the position operators of the proton and
electron
and the total momentum is the sum of the
individual momenta of the proton and
electron
for the relative coordinates we have
that the relative position is the
difference between the proton and
electron positions
and the relative momentum is given by
this expression in terms of the proton
and electron momenta
with this change of coordinates we now
come to the key result from the video on
two interacting quantum particles
in terms of this new set of coordinates
we can rewrite the hamiltonian of the
hydrogen atom as equal to a kinetic
energy term that involves the total
momentum
a kinetic energy term involving the
relative momentum and a potential energy
term involving the relative coordinate
in this expression here the capital m is
the total mass of the system and is
given by the sum of the two masses
and the mu here is the reduced mass of
the system and is given by this
expression
for completeness let me also mention
that we often encounter the defining
relation for the reduced mass written
like this a form that is completely
equivalent to the original one
so what have we accomplished with this
change of coordinates in the original
hamiltonian up here the interaction term
depends on the position operators of
both the proton and the electron
such an interaction term makes this a
two particle problem
if we now look at the transformed
hamiltonian down here we see that the
interaction term only depends on the
relative position operator but does not
depend on operators associated with the
center of mass
as we'll see in a moment this means that
we can now describe the hydrogen atom as
two separate one particle problems which
is a much simpler setup than the
original two particle problem
let's see how this comes about
if we look at this transformed
hamiltonian for the hydrogen atom we see
that this first term only depends on
center of mass coordinates so we can
call it the center of mass hamiltonian
while these two terms only depend on the
relative coordinates so we can call them
the relative hamiltonian
let's first consider the center of mass
hamiltonian
it looks like the hamiltonian of a
single particle of total mass capital n
therefore we can think of it as
describing the motion of a fictitious
particle whose mass is the total mass of
the system
furthermore as the only term is the
kinetic energy term this hamiltonian
describes the motion of a free particle
let's now consider the relative
hamiltonian
it looks like the hamiltonian of a
single particle of mass mu
moving in an electrostatic potential
centered at the origin of
coordinates again we can also think of
it as describing the motion of a
fictitious particle this time of mass mu
moving in an electrostatic potential
so what does all of this mean
the center of mass of the hydrogen atom
behaves like a free particle so without
loss of generality we can simply assume
that the center of mass is stationary
and just forget about it
the interesting physics of the hydrogen
atom are therefore captured by the
relative motion of the proton electron
as described by this hamiltonian and
this will be our main focus in the study
of the hydrogen atom
so overall what have we accomplished
hydrogen is a two particle system
however by a smart choice of coordinates
we have shown how we can reduce the
problem to the study of the relative
motion of the two particles and this
relative motion is described by this
hamiltonian here that looks like the
hamiltonian of a single particle and
mathematically this is a much easier
problem to solve
and let me remind you again that this
discussion of the center of mass and
relative coordinates builds on the video
on two interacting quantum particles
that is linked in the description so
check it out if you need a refresher
let me discuss one final point before we
finish
i hope i've convinced you that using
this hamiltonian for the relative motion
of the proton and electron will help us
solve the mathematics associated with
the hydrogen atom and indeed this is
precisely what we do in some of the
other videos on hydrogen
to be precise we treat the system as a
single fictitious particle whose
momentum is the relative momentum of the
proton and electron here whose mass is
the reduced mass of the proton and
electron here and whose position is the
relative position of the proton and
electron here
but how can we conceptually understand
this fictitious particle
to do so we need to go all the way back
to the large difference in mass between
the electron and the proton and use it
to put some numbers into the parameters
featuring in the center of mass and
relative coordinates
first let's consider the center of mass
position
remember that it is given by this
expression
and as the proton mass is much larger
than the electron mass this denominator
is approximately equal to the proton
mass
with this we can now approximate the
center of mass position as equal to the
proton position
plus me over mp times the electron
position
this ratio is of the order of 10 to the
minus 3
which means that we can approximate this
whole expression by simply the proton
position
what does this mean because of the large
mass difference between the proton and
the electron the center of mass position
pretty much coincides with the proton
position
now try to remember this and
let's consider the reduced mass of this
system
remember that the inverse of mu is given
by this expression
as the mass of the proton is much larger
than the mass of the electron then the
inverse mass of the proton is much
smaller than the inverse mass of the
electron
this means that we can approximate this
expression by 1 over me
and rearranging we find that the reduced
mass of the system is approximately
equal to the electron mass
so what does all of this mean
we know that this hamiltonian up here
describes a fictitious particle of mass
mu associated with the relative motion
of the proton and electron
but we've just found that the huge mass
difference between the proton and
electron implies that the center of mass
position is very close to the proton
position and that the reduced mass is
very close to the electron mass
this means that the fictitious particle
is in fact almost equal to an electron
moving about a stationary proton
and this is the intuition that we were
looking for
we can do a good approximation think
about hydrogen as simply having a
stationary proton and only consider the
motion of the electron
now this analogy would in fact be exact
if the proton mass was infinite as in
that case the proton would indeed be
stationary
in fact when we move from hydrogen to
the heavier isotopes deuterium or
tritium this is precisely what happens
treating the nucleus as stationary
becomes an increasingly good
approximation
overall this is a helpful way to
conceptually think about the problem but
we know that it is technically not quite
correct because although the proton mass
is much larger than that of the electron
it is not quite infinitely larger
for an exact mathematical solution we of
course have to solve the actual relative
hamiltonian
the hydrogen atom is a key quantum
system in all of physics chemistry and
material science
hydrogen is a two particle system made
of a proton and an electron however
we've seen today that we can map this
two body problem onto two simpler one
body problems one describing the motion
of the center of mass of the hydrogen
atom and another one describing the
relative motion between the proton and
the electron as a next step i would
suggest that you watch the videos where
we solve the eigenvalue equation of the
hamiltonian of the hydrogen atom and
that will help us to learn about its
energy levels and its energy
eigenfunctions and as always if you
liked the video please subscribe